qué tal buenas noches alan no en
realidad no voten contra voté a favor
pero si estuve muy confundida hasta el
día anterior a la votación
y yo manifesté que lo tome la decisión
después de una charla con mi nieta que
en ese momento tenía 13 años hoy tiene
15 años y en una forma tan adulta me
explicaba la situación y la problemática
de las niñas y de las adolescentes y eso
es lo que me permitió cambiar de opinión
que sigue ahora la ley deberá ser
promulgada por el presidente alberto
fernández y reglamentada para que
comience a implementarse en todo el país
cuando la provisión de los abortos
recaiga sobre el descentralizado sector
de la salud que desafío se enfrenta a
este proceso
no obviamente que en 10 días creo que
ella va a estar promulgada la ley
publicada en el boletín oficial y
comienza la reglamentación así que va a
hacer casi en forma inmediata estamos en
un periodo no esté difícil pero
obviamente que que en el mes de enero yo
entiendo a más tardar febrero va a estar
esté en vigencia la ley no todos
celebraron diputada los llamados
pro-vida identificados por su color
celeste amenazan con recurrir a la
justicia qué acciones pueden hacer
no pueden recurrir a la justicia pero ya
lo dijeron algunos abogados
constitucionalistas y abogados este
referente a esto de familias que es
difícil que ante una ley esté la
justicia este tome una decisión bueno
hay muchos fallos en otras actividades
donde la ley donde en la corte suprema
se ha apartado porque no tiene
facultades legislativa eso es lo que
dice así que no creo que llegue adelante
a buen puerto la presentación judicial
que hace falta diputada para que en
américa latina una región con varios
sistemas políticos federales se viva una
situación como la que está viviendo ya
argentina
tomar conciencia del peligro que corren
las mujeres aquí en argentina 450.000
mujeres murieron por abortos
clandestinos pero lo que se necesita es
una muy buena educación sexual porque el
aborto es algo que se tiene que llegar
al final creo que este en américa tienen
que tomar conciencia de esta necesidad
de la mujer pero fundamentalmente
educación sexual para evitar llegar al
aborto se llama este amor en la ley de
interrupción del embarazo este
voluntario y gratuito pero en verdad la
ley es más amplia es la educación sexual
es pues contención a través de equipos
técnicos y además este otro proyecto que
es el de los mil días para aquellas que
después de una charla importantes con
terapeutas tomen la decisión de seguir
con sus embarazos de contener al niño
hasta los tres años esté socialmente
económicamente y a través de la salud
creo que se debe todo este debate en
américa latina' muchas gracias diputada
por esta comunicación por compartirnos
su historia familiar ella es legisladora
argentina
el frente renovador